getting Shiny Pokemon has never been
easier in a Mainline Pokemon game here
are a few strategies that will
significantly increase your odds of
running into a Shiny Pokemon in scarlet
and violet now before we get going I
highly recommend teaching one of your
Pokemon false swipe the last thing you
want to do is to knock out a Shiny
Pokemon before you catch it and this
move will prevent that from happening
you can get the false swipe TM from
Jacques I also recommend picking up
quick balls as these will greatly
improve your catch rates at the
beginning of a battle and using a
Pokemon that can put wild Pokemon to
sleep finally I recommend turning off
autosave in the main menu
Pokemon outbreaks from Legends are CSR
back and this is the best way to find
Shiny Pokemon early on open up your map
to find a Pokemon outbreak head to that
location and start battling the outbreak
Pokemon the more you defeat the more
your odds will improve in general the
odds of running into a Shiny Pokemon are
one out of 4096 however after defeating
30 outbreak Pokemon the odds increased
to 1 out of every 2048. after 60 it goes
to 1 out of 1
365. once you hit 60 save your game and
set up a picnic after you've released
your Pokemon from their pokeballs pack
up the picnic and take a look around if
there are no shinies start up another
picnic and repeat the process try not to
knock out too many more Pokemon because
if you knock out too many the outbreak
will end if that does happen just reload
your save every time you set up and pack
up a picnic all the Pokemon in the area
reset this means that new Pokemon will
load in much quicker than they would
otherwise which means you can burn
through Pokemon spawns far quick keep in
mind that the picnic strategy could be a
bug so it may get patched out eventually
one out of 1 336 still aren't the best
odds fortunately there is a way to
improve shiny odds in Pokemon scarlet
and violet across the board all you need
to do is catch every single Pokemon in
the pound Pokedex and talk to Jack it's
a Time sink and you'll need to
coordinate some trades across versions
but your shiny odds will be globally
adjusted to 1 out of 2048. if you defeat
60 Pokemon during an outbreak that will
improve your odds even further now if
you're really into shiny hunting
completing the Pokedex is 100 worth your
time it can be a pain especially when
there's only a handful of entries left
to fill but it can make this whole
process so much smoother
sandwiches are new to Pokemon scarlet
and violet and they along with a bunch
of other Buffs can dramatically increase
shiny rates the key ingredient is
irvamistica in order to get Urban
mystica you need to unlock 5 Star Terror
rides by completing the game and some
post-game content the catch is that 5
Star raids can be pretty tough
especially by yourself however if you
coordinate with some friends and plan
accordingly you should be able to take
them out if you have no friends you can
match make with other players but
matchmaking isn't super reliable there
are five flavors of urban mystica you
can find salty spicy Sweet Bitter and
sour flavor combinations combined with
an ingredient correspond to different
types for this Pomo I used a yellow bell
pepper and salty and spicy Urban mystica
there are a bunch of combinations that
players are still figuring out so if
you're hunting for a specific shiny I
recommend looking up the proper
ingredients before you start making
Urban mystica sandwiches
the Masuda Method is a shiny hunting
strategy reserved specifically for
Pokemon breeding in order to breed you
need two compatible Pokemon and one must
be from another real world region if
you're unsure what region a Pokemon is
from you can check its summary page the
easiest way to get a Pokemon from
another region is through surprise
traits connect to the internet select
poker portal hit surprise trade and
offer up a Pokemon within seconds you
should get a random Pokemon from another
trainer the other way to get Pokemon
from another region is by starting a new
game and selecting a different language
if you plan on picking up both scarlet
and violet you can set your second game
to a different language ideally you'd
want to catch an alternate ditto so you
can breed any Pokemon with improved odds
of course the shiny charm will improve
your odds even further thanks to
sandwiches you can give your Pokemon an
egg boost which should increase breeding
success this won't increase your shiny
odds but it does mean you'll get more
eggs in a shorter amount of time when
you're hatching I also recommend having
a Pokemon with the ability flame body in
your party because that will also cause
eggs to hatch quicker once you've found
two partner Pokemon make sure they are
the only ones in your party eat an egg
boosting meal and set your switch down
for the next 30 minutes or so once
you're ready check this basket and
you'll have a ton of eggs to hatch shiny
hunting can be a long process but
scarlet and violet have made some
substantial changes that make it much
easier if you have any more tips or
you're just looking for someone to team
up with for a 5 Star raid please leave a
comment down below
thank you
[Music]
thank you